bonjour jean marc mais vraiment très
très heureux de vous accueillir ce matin
en vrai entre la matinale de rtl france
on a fait cette chronique échos jusqu'à
présent à distance pour les raisons
sanitaires alors on va parler du bitcoin
au salvador une décision qui fait
l'effet d'un coup de tonnerre évidemment
dans les milieux financiers parce que
c'est la première fois qu'un
gouvernement légalise le bitcoin ça
amuse les spéculateurs et ça inquiète
les banquiers et on l'a vu à la
population oui alors dans un premier
temps la décision de donner aux mobiles
cogne un cours légal avait été prise en
juin je crois par le président du
salvador c'était pas un peu passé
inaperçu mais là les transactions du
beacon commence à s'amplifier ça
concerne de plus en plus de monde alors
tout le monde s'en préoccupent alors le
salvador c'est un tout petit pays un à
six ou sept millions d'habitants ils
sont surtout célèbres pour leurs plages
de surf il travaille beaucoup d'un
étranger il y en a pratiquement un
million qui travaillent à l'étranger et
ces gens qui travaillent à l'étranger
ils envoient de l'argent à leur famille
à peu près tous les mois ou tous les
quinze jours et ils envoyaient jusqu'à
lier avec du dollar mais le dollar on
payait une les transaction était soumise
à une commission de transfert qui
représentait à peu près 3 pour soir
président du sabbe alors c'est libre
passion hobbit cogne et comme ça on va
faire sauter la la commission alors on
gagne plus on gagne un peu sur le change
et par ailleurs comme le bitcoin est une
maman est une monnaie qui monte dont le
cours monte lorsque les salles bat de l
aile les habitants du salvador chandler
bitcoin en dollars et récupère plus
dollars donc isolé l'impression de
gagner dans un premier temps sauf que
c'est une c'est une monnaie dont le
cours est très fluctuant parfois ça
monte souvent ça monte mais parfois ça
baisse alors jean marc comment a t'on
gardé la valeur du mythe alors le
problème c'est la garantie effectivement
il faut savoir que que la monnaie
officielle du salvador c'est le dollar
c'est ils n'ont pas leur propre monnaie
donc ils utilisent le bitcoin mais le
been called sa valeur n'est garantie que
par la valeur du marché c'est-à-dire
qu'on évalue à chaque instant la valeur
du beacon en fonction de l'offre et de
la demande alors comme c'est un marché
fermé il ya une masse de bitcoin en
circulation dans le monde qu'il
n'augmente pas la valeur augmente si
vous avez plus de demande et jusqu'à
maintenant la demande a toujours été
supérieure à l'offre le bitcoin hier
soir devait côté à peu près dans les
trente neuf mille neuf cent euros il a
valu jusqu'à 41 42 me il a tendance à
structurellement montée il est parti à
10 ans à quelques euros donc la valeur
dépend de l'offre et de la demande donc
çà çà çà soumet les laisse les les
habitants du salvador à la aux facéties
du marché et surtout à la spéculation et
une incertitude est aussi sa valeur oui
à court terme mais souvenez-vous de
cette affaire un lunch and must toujours
à la pointe de la mode en matière de
communication avait dit j'accepte qu'on
achète des voitures tesla en les payant
bitcoins le bitcoin a explosé sur les
marchés et il est monté jusqu'à plus de
42 à 40 premiers et puis il ya quelques
temps et à c'est un peu avant l'été il
s'est aperçu qu'on lui a fait remarquer
que le bitcoin était une tête une
monnaie pas écologique puisque le
bitcoin pour pouvoir calculer sa valeur
on est obligé de faire fonctionner à la
blocs chaîne la bloque chaîne c'est quoi
c'est l'ensemble des ordinateurs qui qui
accumule l'ensemble des transactions
pour savoir que que ça s'est bien passé
et ça consomme énormément d'électricité
et des énormément d'énergie l'ensemble
des transactions bicol doit doit
consommer dans le monde plus que la
production d'une centrale nucléaire donc
c'est pour les écolos c'est pas c'est
pas une monnaie qui est
vêtements un sandow helmes supprime la
possibilité d'acheter les voitures des
saran bitcoin du coup le bitcoin
abc très violemment et puis maintenant
il s'est hissé il s'est rétabli parce
qu'il ya d'autres acheteurs dans le cas
du salvador la population s'est inquiété
des soubresauts on le voit bien et
surtout les organisations
internationales comme le fmi la banque
mondiale ont considéré qu'il y avait pas
de contrôle qui avait pas trente actions
et on sait très bien que le bitcoin est
souvent utilisé pour faire du
blanchiment d'argent du crime d'argent
sale d'agents du thé et de l'argent du
terrorisme le sa valeur étant un petit
pays au milieu là de l'amérique du sud
enfin sur la côte de l'amérique centrale
sur la côte pacifique les contrôles sont
pas forcément évident et est-ce que
l'exemple du salvador il pourrait être
imité par effectivement beaucoup de pays
qui regarde ça c'est quand même assez
peu probable parce que la monnaie vous
c'est un marqueur d'identité ça marque
un de souveraineté vous êtes un vrai
pays quand vous avez des frontières un
drapeau éventuellement un hymne national
et puis une monnaie et la monnaie elle
est contrôlée par 6 essais le sait le
marqueur de l'état souverain contrôlés
par une banque centrale
et donc les autorités c'est ça qui
garantit la monnaie et qui mesure son
crédit international qui lui permet
d'emprunter de prêter donc dans la
sphère du soldat dans les organisations
internationales n'ont pas interdit
formellement l'utilisation du bitcoin
mais elles ont demandé au gouvernement
d'apporter des garanties de transparence
de prouver que c'est bine codes ne sont
pas utilisés pour blanchir de l'argent
de créer ou du terrorisme le seul moyen
serait de consulter à chaque fois la
blood chaîne qui centralise toutes les
utilisations depuis le début mais ça
c'est un travail gigantesque que
personne ne fait ça ajoute que dans le
cas du salvador qui vit dans leur vie
des états unis cette décision a été
prise un peu pour s'affranchir des
amériques à une petite manoeuvre
politique qui n'empêchera pas que ça
j'adore quand même de se plier aux
injonctions du fmi ou de la banque
mondiale dès qu'il aura besoin de
dollars parce que il va continuer à
avoir besoin de dollars et oui merci
beaucoup jean marc sylvestre c'est
l'édito est qu en vrai nom la matinale
c'est bien des victoires trouver sur les
réseaux sociaux bien évidemment